what's your favorite central casting
extra work soaring my favorite one
there's a couple but there was one where
I worked my first day on the show called
without a trace
it's a CBS show yeah and I went there
you know it was one of those big casting
calls we had to go a day early to get
dressed up in some prison outfit so I'm
like are I'm just gonna be a prison dude
then when we actually went on a set they
had this whole place rented out the
whole prison thing set up and it was a
basketball court you know I like to play
basketball so I just pick up the bone I
just started playing with a couple of
the extras and they weren't pretty good
so I kind of stood out and the director
was like hey hey you I want to use you
in the scene just do this with this
actor and this I'm like this is
fantastic
so I did the thing and you know as a
couple of extras there we're trying to
upstage me of course then at the end of
the day you know you usually share an
extra you get a non-union voucher and
it's my first gig so I'm thinking I'm
going in that line he was like hey
you're the guy coming out here on this
line and I remember noticing all the
extras just giving me dirty looks and I
was like okay what's going on then since
it was a three day thing the first day
did whatever they gave me two SAG
vouchers on my first no extra work for
central and you know I didn't have my
car at a time so one of the extras took
me home after he shot and the whole way
there he was just telling me how lucky I
was
he hated my guts all that and cuz he had
been doing it for like five years and he
barely had one so I was interesting this
was your first my first extra job for
central casting so what would you advise
other people about doing extra work
because there are sort of unspoken rules
that you do learn after watching and
being burned you're absolutely right
what I learned was just like I said like
the ins and outs of what you're allowed
to do and which were not allowed to do
because some people try to upstage or
even try to get and just in the camera
cite me basically it was just learning I
was just paying attention to what the
actors were doing offset like are they
one of those actors that just takes
their script goes it away jokes around
one of those actors that really just
takes his stuff goes in his room and
gold falls in love with that scene he
did that was pretty much it I saw I was
like okay and the ones that I knew that
were character actors I kind of accident
sir ting questions but extras like once
again you're only allowed certain things
are allowed to talk to certain people
you can't initiate conversation and all
that so how to learn the ins and outs of
being an extra which is an experience
I'd say
you